Mitchell was in his 20s when he learned that his mom was getting on a bus or train twice a week and going to a place that would stick a needle in her arm and take a pint of blood. And they would keep the plasma and give her back everything else and pay her $25 or $35 per pint. Again, she'd do this twice a week because she needed the cash. And of course, that is not the kind of thing anybody wants to hear their mom has to do. And it took him a few years, but soon as he had the money to step in and help her out, Mitchell told his mom, don't do it anymore. You know, I'll just give you the money. And she turned him down.
米切尔20多岁时发现，他母亲每周有两次会搭乘公交车或火车，去一个地方让人往她手臂上扎针，抽走一品脱血液。他们会留下血浆，把剩下的部分回输给她，并为此支付每品脱25到35美元。再说一次，她每周要这么做两次，因为她需要这笔钱。当然，没有人愿意听到自己的母亲不得不做这种事。他花了几年时间，但一旦他有钱能介入并帮助她时，米切尔告诉他母亲，别再这么做了。他说：“钱我直接给你就行。”但她拒绝了他。
You know, like, don't worry about it. I don't need you to jump in. I'll take care of myself. Even if it's hubris, at least I'm not asking you for anything. She loves that saying-- what does she say? "We do for today what we can't do for forever."
她说：“别担心，不用你来帮我，我自己能照顾好自己。”即使这是一种傲慢，至少我没有向你索要任何东西。她喜欢那句格言——她是怎么说的来着？“我们今天做的事，是为了未来无法做到的事。”
What's that mean?
那是什么意思？
It's, I guess, a personal proverb that she uses to trick herself into enduring a crucible. You know? I can do it today.
我想，这大概是她用来欺骗自己以忍受磨难的一条个人箴言。你知道吗？我今天能做到。
What made this especially hard was Mitchell was in New York. His mom was on the other side of the country in Oregon, where he grew up. And he'd call sometimes, and her phone would be turned off. And he would have to reach out to his brothers to find out what was happening and if she needed help and then organize the help.
让这件事尤为困难的是，米切尔当时在纽约，而他母亲在国家的另一端——俄勒冈州，那是他长大的地方。他有时打电话过去，她的手机却是关机的。他不得不去联系他的兄弟们，查明发生了什么事，她是否需要帮助，然后再组织援手。
But talking to her about the blood donations-- and they had a bunch of conversations about it-- led Mitchell to learn everything about it, about the multibillion dollar companies that buy plasma from people like his mom, about the Black doctor, Charles Drew, who invented a way of separating plasma from blood and set up some of America's first blood banks at the start of World War II.
但是，与她谈论献血的事——他们为此进行了多次谈话——促使米切尔了解了其中的一切：关于那些从他母亲这类人手中购买血浆的数十亿美元公司，关于黑人医生查尔斯·德鲁（Charles Drew），他在二战初期发明了一种从血液中分离血浆的方法，并建立了美国首批血库。
And because we were still in Jim Crow, they would not let Black people donate blood. Like, how symbolic is that that the Black guy that invents this process that helps these hundreds of thousands, if not millions, of people can't even donate blood?
而且由于当时美国仍实行吉姆·克劳法（种族隔离制度），他们不让黑人捐血。想想看，这有多么讽刺啊，那位发明了这种能帮助成千上万，甚至数百万人的工艺的黑人，竟然自己都不能捐血？
Mitchell is a writer. He's been on our show before-- Mitchell S. Jackson. And he's written about these conversations with his mom and the places that they led him to. Like, for instance, one day, he got her talking about blood and patriotism. His mom's take on patriotism, by the way, is that anybody who says my country right or wrong, no matter what ugly thing happens here, is basically just like a mom, who sees the best in her kid no matter what terrible thing they do. Anyway, during that conversation, she surprised Mitchell by describing her blood donations as the most patriotic thing she does, even though she does it for the money.
米切尔是一位作家。他以前上过我们的节目——米切尔·S·杰克逊（Mitchell S. Jackson）。他写过关于这些与他母亲的谈话，以及这些对话将他带往的地方。比如有一天，他引出母亲谈论血液与爱国主义。顺便说一句，他母亲对爱国主义的看法是，任何说“我的祖国，无论对错，无论这里发生了什么丑事”的人，基本上就像一位母亲，无论自己的孩子做了什么可怕的事，她都能看到孩子最好的一面。总之，在那次谈话中，她让米切尔感到惊讶，她称自己的献血是她所做的最爱国的事情，尽管她是为了钱才这么做的。
I guess if we kind of think about patriotism in its best light, it's looking out for the next person. She was just thinking, I'm giving a part of me which is sacred to benefit someone else. But I think it's also, too, my mother is one of those people. She really is the mother who will do anything. She's the mother that has, like, $100 in her account to last her the month. And my brother doesn't have food in his refrigerator, and she gives him 80. And this is not a hypothetical. This is a literal. So this is another way of giving.
我想，如果我们从最好的角度去理解爱国主义，那就是关照身边的人。她当时只是在想，我献出身体的一部分，这部分是神圣的，是为了造福他人。但我认为，这也是因为我母亲就是那种人。她真的是那种为了孩子什么都愿意做的母亲。她是那种账户里只剩下100美元来支撑整个月，而我兄弟的冰箱里没吃的，她会给他80美元的母亲。这不是假设，这是事实。所以这也是一种奉献方式。
Mitchell, as you talk about it, I just feel so struck with all the things that are bundled up in those little pints of plasma. When you tell this story, it's simultaneously your feeling of protectiveness about her and how she's doing, and is she doing OK, and her wanting to be independent of you and her also feeling like she's taking care of other people and also getting money she needs. And also, it's blood, this physical thing that's all compressed in this little plastic bag, you know?
米切尔，当你谈到这一点时，我被那些装在小品脱血浆袋里的所有东西深深触动了。当你讲述这个故事时，它同时包含了你对她的保护欲，担心她过得怎么样，她还好吗；而她则想保持独立，不依赖你，同时也觉得自己是在照顾他人，并且得到了她所需的金钱。而且这毕竟是血液，这种被压缩在小小塑料袋里的实体，你知道吗？
Yeah, it's both symbolic and literal.
是的，它既是象征性的，也是字面意义上的。
I think it's always that way, maybe because blood is so fundamental, keeping us alive. It's something we all share, part of our insides that we all have actually seen with the urgent color of a stop sign. It takes on so many other meanings in ways that other things in our body do not. There's blood ties and blood feuds and bad blood between people and the blood of the lamb, and Jesus's blood turned to wine. There's the idea of people who are cold-blooded, people who are hot-blooded, and the now discredited notion of how much of this group's blood or that group's blood you have running through your veins.
我想情况总是这样，也许是因为血液是如此根本，维系着我们的生命。它是我们共同分享的东西，是我们体内的一部分，我们都见过它那如停车标志般紧急的颜色。它被赋予了太多其他含义，这是我们身体的其他部分所没有的。有血缘关系，有血海深仇，人与人之间有“坏血”（宿怨），有羔羊之血，有耶稣变成酒的血。还有关于冷血的人、热血的人的观念，以及现在已被推翻的论调——关于你血管里流淌着多少这个群体或那个群体的血。
Today, on our program, we dive into all kinds of stories about blood. Picture please, if you will, right now, you know those elevator doors from The Shining opening up a sea of blood pouring out right here on the radio? But don't touch that dial. There is so much to say. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Bloody stay with us.
今天，在我们的节目中，我们将深入探讨各种关于血液的故事。请想象一下，如果你愿意的话，现在，你知道《闪灵》里那些电梯门打开，涌出如海的鲜血的情景吗？现在就在电台里发生了。但请别转台，还有很多话要说。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请保持收听。
Act One, Started From Phle-Bottom, Now We're Here. So we begin today with a story about literal, actual blood and this joke-- and by the way, hello to all the seven-year-olds in our audience-- why did the nurse bring a red pen to work? In case she had to draw blood. OK, anyway, somebody wrote into our show last summer saying they had a story to tell about being a phlebotomist, a person whose job it is to draw blood for lab tests or donations-- using, by the way, a needle, not a red pen.
第一幕，“从静脉底层开始，现已功成名就”。所以，我们今天从一个关于真实血液的故事和这个笑话开始——顺便问候我们听众中所有的七岁孩子们——为什么护士上班带一支红笔？以防她需要“抽血”（draw blood，双关语，也有画血的意思）。好吧，总之，去年夏天有人给我们节目写信，说他们有一个关于做静脉穿刺师的故事，这是一个负责为实验室化验或捐献抽血的工作——顺便说一句，是用针，而不是红笔。
Her name is Adele Levine. And she said she was the worst phlebotomist in her whole hospital. One of our producers, Diane Wu, found that intriguing, naturally called her up, and it turns out she is a perfectly fine phlebotomist. But she did get thrown into the job from a different job without a lot of preparation in some of the most extreme circumstances imaginable-- a total fish out of water. Here's Diane.
她叫阿黛尔·莱文（Adele Levine）。她说她是整个医院最差的静脉穿刺师。我们的一位制片人黛安·吴（Diane Wu）觉得这很吸引人，自然就给她打了电话，结果发现她其实是一名非常优秀的静脉穿刺师。但她确实是在没有多少准备的情况下，从另一份工作被调入了这个岗位，处在极其极端的环境下——完全是一个脱离了本行的“旱鸭子”。下面请听黛安的报道。
I liked talking to Adele about drawing blood because as a newbie, she saw everything with beginner's eyes. She was so into it. She talked about veins in this way that I'd never heard before-- just ardently.
我和阿黛尔谈论抽血这件事很有趣，因为作为新手，她用初学者的眼光看一切。她非常投入。她谈论血管的方式是我从未听过的——极其狂热。
You have to test the vein, and it should feel bouncy.
你必须测试一下血管，它应该感觉有弹性。
Like, you test it by touching it with your finger?
你是说，用手指触摸来测试吗？
Yeah, I would touch it, and it should sort of bounce. So now I'm always bouncing veins, my own veins.
对，我会摸它，它应该有回弹。所以现在我总是会去按弹自己的血管，我自己的血管。
Wait, now I want to try.
等等，现在我也想试试。
Oh, do it on the back of your hand.
哦，在你的手背上试。
OK.
好的。
Yeah, the veins in the front of the wrist are not for us.
是的，手腕内侧的血管不是给我们抽的。
How come?
为什么？
I don't know. I didn't go to phlebotomy school. They just told me, that's not for us.
我不知道。我没去过静脉穿刺学校。他们只是告诉我，那不是我们要抽的。
Adele didn't ever study phlebotomy because she's actually a physical therapist. She had no plans to ever be sticking people with needles and drawing their blood. But when COVID hit last spring, the hospital she worked at cancelled all of her physical therapy appointments and started assigning people to new jobs.
阿黛尔从未学习过静脉穿刺，因为她实际上是一名物理治疗师。她从未打算用针扎人并抽取血液。但去年春天疫情来袭时，她工作的医院取消了她所有的物理治疗预约，并开始给员工分配新工作。
I really wanted to work on the loading dock. That was what I really wanted to do. I wanted to drive one of those big things around and lift pallets of supplies.
我真的很想在装卸码头工作。那才是我真正想做的。我想驾驶那些大家伙，搬运供应托盘。
But they didn't need her there. She ended up in phlebotomy, one of the departments of the hospital whose work didn't slow down, and became a total newbie drafted to draw blood for the very first time in the middle of a pandemic. By the way, she didn't want us to name her hospital because they didn't give her permission to do an interview. Adele spent her first few days following different phlebotomists around the hospital, watching closely as they worked. She was so impressed to watch as they performed even the most basic tasks with incredible elegance.
但他们那里不需要她。她最终被分配到了静脉穿刺部门，这是医院里工作没有放缓的科室之一。她成了一名完全的新手，在疫情期间第一次被征召去抽血。顺便说一句，她不让我们说出医院的名字，因为他们没有允许她接受采访。阿黛尔前几天一直跟着医院里不同的静脉穿刺师跑，仔细观察他们的工作。看着他们以令人难以置信的优雅完成哪怕最基本的任务，她印象深刻。
This one phlebotomist, I just was always mesmerized by the way she put tape on the back of her hand so precisely, always exactly the exact size piece of tape. Another one, she would hold the butterfly needle not by the wings, but actually by the little barrel, which is kind of a harder way to hold it, but she was just real gentle, just the way they could draw blood from the craziest places.
其中一位穿刺师，我总是被她把胶带贴在手背上的那种精准度所吸引，每一片胶带的大小都恰到好处。另一位，她拿蝴蝶针的方法不是捏住翅膀，而是捏住小管身，这其实是一种更难的握法，但她真的非常温柔，那种从最疯狂的地方抽取血液的方式简直神了。
I mean, because hospital patients, they're sick. They're in organ failure. They're really swollen, or their veins are shot. And these phlebotomists are doing crazy stuff, like just skimming the surface of someone's forearm and just getting this tiny little spider vein, you know? Or they're getting blood from the back of someone's thumb knuckle. I think they're total artists.
我的意思是，因为医院的病人病得很重。他们器官衰竭，身体严重肿胀，或者血管已经废了。而这些穿刺师在做着疯狂的事情，比如仅仅掠过某人的前臂表面，就能扎到这根细小的静脉，你知道吗？或者他们能从某人的拇指指节背面抽到血。我认为他们完全是艺术家。
Then, suddenly, it was her turn to try. Adele flipped around her hospital badge so no one could see she was a physical therapist, then went and did her first sticks-- that's phlebotomist lingo for blood draws-- in the maternity ward on healthy young mothers who had big, easily visible veins. She made a lot of rookie mistakes.
然后，突然轮到她试了。阿黛尔翻转了她的医院胸牌，这样就没人能看到她是物理治疗师，然后她去了产科病房，进行了她的第一次“扎针”——这是穿刺师的行话，指抽血——对象是那些拥有粗壮、清晰可见血管的健康年轻母亲。她犯了很多新手错误。
I would keep the tube on until it completely filled with blood. And then when I would retract the needle, the blood that was left over in the tubing would spill all over the bed and make a big mess. And then everyone was always yelling at me to retract the needle, retract it. Do it, do it. It's ready. It's ready. I'm like, but it's only halfway full. Just do it! I'm like, OK.
我会一直让试管连着针管，直到它完全装满血。然后当我撤回针头时，软管里剩下的血就会溅得到处都是，弄得床上一团糟。然后每个人都在冲我喊：“撤出针头，快撤！”我说：“但它才装了一半啊。”他们说：“快撤！准备好了，准备好了。”我说：“好吧。”
After about two weeks of this sort of haphazard seat-of-the-pants training, her manager decided she was ready to go in alone. On her first day of working solo, Adele walked in and saw that her assignment was in the ICU, which, at that point in April, was full of COVID patients.
在经过大约两周这种随意的、临时抱佛脚式的训练后，她的经理认为她可以独立工作了。在独立工作的第一天，阿黛尔走进去，发现她的任务是在ICU（重症监护室），那是四月份的时候，里面全是新冠肺炎患者。
I got panicked, completely panicked, you know? I mean--
我陷入了恐慌，完全恐慌了，你知道吗？我的意思是——
Why?
为什么？
--I was so nervous. I mean, even just going into a COVID room just would fill me with fear, terror.
——我太紧张了。我的意思是，哪怕只是走进新冠病房，都会让我充满恐惧和战栗。
It was an incredibly challenging assignment. ICU patients were among the sickest in the hospital, often with multiple IVs and swollen limbs. And phlebotomy was only called in after the nurses there had already tried twice to get blood, but couldn't. On top of that, all the COVID stuff-- the PPE that made it hard to move and see, not being able to bring a full cart of supplies in, the pressure to work quickly and minimize exposure. Adele was terrified and overwhelmed. But she did her best to figure out her own little routine.
这是一项极具挑战性的任务。ICU病人是医院里最重的病人，通常身上插着多根静脉输液管，肢体肿胀。而且静脉穿刺部门通常是在护士已经尝试了两次无法抽到血后才会被叫过来。最重要的是，所有的防疫装备——这些防护服让人难以移动和视线受阻，没法带完整的推车进去，还要承受快速工作并尽量减少暴露的压力。阿黛尔感到恐惧和不知所措。但她尽最大努力摸索出了一套自己的小流程。
In the beginning, I always used to talk to the patients, even though--
一开始，我总是会和病人说话，尽管——
What would you say?
你会说什么？
I would say-- I'm like, good morning, good morning. This is Adele. I'm from phlebotomy. I'm here to draw some blood. But they're sedated, or I tell them, today's Tuesday. It's April 20. It's a nice day outside. I'd tell them what's on the news or what was going on. And I'd always tell them that they look great, that they were getting better, I could tell.
我会说——我说，早上好，早上好。我是阿黛尔，来自静脉穿刺部。我来给您抽点血。但他们要么处于镇静状态，要么我就告诉他们，今天是星期二，4月20日。外面天气很好。我会告诉他们新闻上说了什么或者发生了什么。我总是告诉他们看起来很棒，他们正在好转，我看得出来。
How often was that actually true?
这话有多少次是真的？
Hardly ever, but I just felt like-- I heard that people, when they're sedated, they can still kind of hear you. So I always felt like I should say something uplifting. I mean, if you want a cheerleading section, I mean, physical therapy is where it's at. I mean, we are so optimistic as a group, you know?
几乎没有，但我只是觉得——我听说人们在镇静状态下，依然能听到你的声音。所以我总觉得我应该说点振奋人心的话。我的意思是，如果你想要一个啦啦队，那肯定得是物理治疗科。我们这群人真的非常乐观，你知道吗？
Adele wasn't doing great at actually getting the blood, though. She was missing something like half of her sticks. She'd get all suited up and prepared to go in the room, try and try and try for 10 or 15 minutes, fail. Then she'd have to go downstairs and mark on the whiteboard the patients that she'd missed so a more experienced phlebotomist could be sent up to try again. She felt like a disappointment, bumbling things up in one of the most serious and urgent parts of the hospital.
不过，阿黛尔在实际抽血方面表现并不出色。她错失了大概一半的针次。她穿好全套防护服准备进入病房，尝试了10到15分钟，失败了。然后她不得不下楼，在白板上标注她没抽到的病人，以便医院派经验更丰富的穿刺师上去再试一次。她觉得自己很失败，在医院最严肃、最紧急的部门里搞砸了事情。
When they would send me to do blood cultures, I would almost always botch it.
当他们派我去做血培养时，我几乎总是会搞砸。
A blood culture is a test for an infection in the blood.
血培养是一项检测血液中是否存在感染的测试。
My first blood culture that I got called to do, when I got to the room, the patient was in a full code. And they were all in there, doing CPR and chest compressions. They were shocking him. I flipped out. I was like, oh my god. I was about to leave, and they're like, no, no. They're like, you stay. They're like, you stay because if he lives, we need those blood cultures. So I stood there. I was waiting, and standing next to me-- we're totally dressed up in all this gear-- was one of the hospital chaplains.
我第一次被叫去做血培养时，当我到达病房，病人正在进行紧急抢救（Full Code）。他们都在那儿，进行心肺复苏和胸部按压。他们在电击他。我吓坏了。我当时想，天哪。我正要离开，他们说，不，不。他们说，你留下。他们说，你必须留下，因为如果他能活下来，我们需要那些血培养。所以我站在那里。我在等待，站在我身边的是一位医院牧师——我们都穿着全套防护装备。
Oh, wow.
哦，天哪。
And we were standing next to each other. She was there because if the patient died, she would need to go in and do last rites. And I got so completely wigged out by that, I started feeling like we were the angel and the devil, just standing side by side. And the patient lived. And the hospital chaplain just flew out of there. And then I had to go in, and I was so rattled by what happened. And then I had to do these blood cultures. It was just-- I didn't get it. I didn't get it.
我们并肩站着。她在那儿是因为如果病人去世了，她需要进去做临终祈祷。我被那个场景吓坏了，我觉得我们就像是天使和魔鬼，并肩站在那里。病人活了下来。医院牧师立刻跑了出去。然后我得进去，我被刚才发生的事情弄得心神不宁。然后我得做这些血培养。这简直是——我没抽到。我没抽到。
Remember, Adele's a physical therapist. Nobody was dying in front of her at her old job. The chaplain never hovered nearby. This was a totally different game. Adele's first week in the ICU was so stressful that she thought about quitting. But she didn't. She kept going. She watched videos about phlebotomy in her free time, practiced getting her sticks over and over, lining up her tubes in the order of the draws, folding gauze into quarters with one hand, readjusting the needle to keep the blood flowing. She started to be able to see veins she couldn't before, to draw blood from more challenging places.
记住，阿黛尔是一名物理治疗师。在她以前的工作岗位上，没人会在她面前死去。牧师也从不会在附近徘徊。这完全是另一回事。阿黛尔在ICU的第一周压力太大了，她想过辞职。但她没有。她坚持了下来。她在空闲时间看关于静脉穿刺的视频，一遍又一遍地练习扎针，按抽血顺序排列试管，用一只手将纱布折成四分之一，调整针头以保持血液流动。她开始能看到以前看不到的血管，能从更有挑战性的地方抽血。
The first time I got blood off this guy's thumb knuckle, yeah, I just couldn't believe it. I was so proud of myself, or from a really skinny little vein, and I'm just trying to-- I just knew if I could just get a centimeter of blood into the tube, that would be good enough for the lab.
第一次从那个人的拇指关节处抽到血时，是的，我简直不敢相信。我当时为自己感到骄傲，或者从那根细小的血管里抽出来，我只知道如果我能抽出一厘米的血到试管里，那对实验室来说就足够了。
But even being able to draw their blood well didn't change her patients' outcomes. Lots died. It got to her. She says she stopped looking at their faces when she went in the room, stopped chatting as much with them, too. And as she was leaving, instead of telling them they looked good and she could tell they were doing better, like she used to, she just told them goodbye. Adele told me that dropping into this tunnel vision mode, just going straight for the vein, not looking around, it actually made her better at drawing blood, more gentle.
但即使能熟练抽血，也并没有改变她病人的结局。很多人去世了。这让她很受打击。她说她不再在进病房时看他们的脸，也不再和他们多聊天了。离开时，她也不再像以前那样告诉他们看起来不错、好转了，只是对他们说再见。阿黛尔告诉我，进入这种隧道视野模式，只专注于血管，不环顾四周，反而让她抽血更好了，更温柔了。
In the middle of the summer, three months after Adele began drawing blood, the first wave finally started to recede at her hospital. Then she got a text from her physical therapy boss, telling her it was time to come back.
夏天中期，在阿黛尔开始抽血三个月后，她所在医院的第一波疫情终于开始消退。然后她收到了物理治疗主管发来的短信，告诉她该回来了。
I was really furious. I didn't want to go back.
我真的很愤怒。我不想回去。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
I caused a bit of a-- yeah, caused a bit of a-- I guess they couldn't believe it. I said I wasn't going to come back.
我闹了点——是的，闹了点——我想他们简直不敢相信。我说我不会回去的。
I was surprised to hear this, given how she'd felt completely inadequate for so long when she was there. But it felt like whiplash to her. She'd been thrown from her old job into this one, finally felt like she knew what she was doing. She wasn't prepared to be yanked back out just as quickly.
听到这个我很惊讶，考虑到她在那儿时一直感到完全力不从心。但这让她感到一种剧烈的震动。她从旧工作被抛入这份新工作中，好不容易觉得自己掌握了诀窍，却没准备好这么快就被强行拉走。
It's been eight months now since Adele switched back to physical therapy. She still notices people's veins, especially the ones on the backs of their fingers. Those ones, she told me, when someone's really sick, those ones will stay bouncy. They're the last to go.
距离阿黛尔回到物理治疗岗位已经过去八个月了。她依然会注意别人的血管，尤其是手指背面那些。她告诉我，当一个人病得很重时，那些血管依然会保持弹性。它们是最后消失的。
Diane Wu is one of the producers of our show.
黛安·吴是我们节目的制片人之一。
Act Two, Blood Ties. So we turn now in this blood episode to blood relatives and the importance of family. Or maybe this story is about the unimportance of family and the meaninglessness of blood ties. At the center of the story are 30 postcards and one of our producers, David Kestenbaum.
第二幕，“血缘关系”。现在，在这个血液特辑中，我们转向血亲和家庭的重要性。或者也许这个故事是关于家庭的不重要以及血缘关系的毫无意义。故事的核心是30张明信片和我们的制片人之一，大卫·克斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）。
I want to start by saying I am one of those people who has never cared at all about family trees, who is related to whom, genealogy, stuff like that. The only family that felt important growing up were the people I saw every day-- my parents and sister, and then, kind of one circle out, grandparents, cousins, the relatives we'd visit with some regularity. Beyond that, they just seemed like people I didn't know. And-- I think this is the scientist in me-- I've always felt like the whole idea of being related by blood, who cares if they have some DNA that I have? It all just seemed kind of dumb.
我想先说，我一直是一个从不在乎家谱、谁和谁有亲戚关系、家谱学之类东西的人。小时候我觉得重要的家庭成员只有我每天都能见到的人——我的父母和姐姐，然后向外延伸一层，祖父母、堂表亲，也就是我们经常拜访的亲戚。除此之外，他们对我来说就像陌生人。而且——我觉得这是我身上科学的一面——我一直觉得所谓的血缘关系完全是无稽之谈，谁在乎他们是否拥有和我一样的DNA？这一切看起来都很愚蠢。
This was a problem when someone would ask me when my family came to the United States. My great grandparents? I think from Austria or Poland, some from Russia. At various points, it's felt like a thing I should know, just so I could not look like an idiot when that question came up. So I'd ask my parents, who'd tell me. But there weren't a lot of details. No one felt real in it. And whatever my parents would tell me, I'd promptly forget.
当有人问我家里人是什么时候移民到美国时，这就成了个问题。我的曾祖父母？我想是来自奥地利或波兰，有些来自俄罗斯。在不同的场合，这感觉像是我应该了解的事情，只是为了不让我在面对这个问题时看起来像个白痴。所以我问过父母，他们会告诉我。但细节并不多。没有人感觉真实。而且无论父母跟我说什么，我转头就会忘掉。
Then a couple of summers ago, we were visiting my aunt and uncle. My kids were running around like lunatics. I was sitting on the couch. And my aunt handed me this stack of papers. They were photocopies of 30 postcards. A distant family member had come across them. And they were beautiful, written in Yiddish and the Hebrew alphabet in this meticulous handwriting.
然后几年前的夏天，我们在拜访叔叔阿姨。我的孩子们像疯子一样跑来跑去。我坐在沙发上。我阿姨递给我一叠纸。那是30张明信片的复印件。一位远房亲戚偶然发现了它们。它们很漂亮，用依地语和希伯来字母书写，笔迹一丝不苟。
I could read who they were addressed to-- that was in English-- Harry Kestenbaum, 320 Cherry Street, New York, America. Cherry Street is a street I've walked by for sure. It runs under the Manhattan Bridge. The postcards were from his father, Shmuel Mendel Kestenbaum, who was living in a town in Austria-Hungary at the foot of a small mountain. The date on the first postcard? 1904. Shmuel was my great, great grandfather's brother.
我能读出它们是寄给谁的——那部分是英文——哈里·克斯滕鲍姆，纽约樱桃街320号，美国。樱桃街是我肯定路过过的一条街。它从曼哈顿大桥下穿过。这些明信片来自他的父亲，什穆埃尔·门德尔·克斯滕鲍姆（Shmuel Mendel Kestenbaum），他住在奥匈帝国的一个小山脚下的小镇。第一张明信片上的日期？1904年。什穆埃尔是我曾曾祖父的兄弟。
There were translations alongside the postcards. A relative had found someone who could read the old Yiddish. So I sat there on the couch and started to read. Again, this wasn't my thing. I honestly didn't expect to get through them. But amazingly, these 30 postcards, they happened to tell a little story with a beginning and an end. You could glimpse a piece of a life through them, of a man living 100 years ago, who had my last name. And I know I just said that shouldn't matter. Maybe I'm wrong. They gave me a feeling I was not expecting to have.
明信片旁边有翻译。一位亲戚找人读懂了旧的依地语。于是我坐在沙发上开始阅读。再说一次，这不是我的菜。我真的没想到自己能读完。但令人惊讶的是，这30张明信片竟然讲了一个有始有终的小故事。你可以通过它们窥见一个100年前的人的一生，他和我有着同样的姓氏。我知道我刚才说那不重要。也许我错了。它们给了我一种我没预料到的感觉。
The postcards are only one side of the conversation, Shmuel writing to his son. But his son, Harry, who is 24 at the beginning, clearly wrote back. You can tell because Shmuel writes things like, "You forgot to put a stamp on your last letter, and I had to pay a fine. Signed, your father, Shmuel." I loved that line because I'm not proud of this, but it reminds me of me.
这些明信片只是对话的一方，是什穆埃尔写给他儿子的。但他的儿子哈里，在开始时是24岁，显然回信了。你可以看出来，因为什穆埃尔写道：“你上封信没贴邮票，害我得交罚款。署名，你的父亲，什穆埃尔。”我喜欢这一行，因为我并不以此为荣，但这让我想起了自己。
And also, it warms my heart to read a guilt trip on 100-year-old postcards sent across an ocean. You can only write like that to someone who's family. Blood gives you permission to make certain demands, to be yourself in ways that maybe you shouldn't. Quote, "You want me to send you a tallis to America?" A tallis is a prayer shawl. "This is quite difficult. Postage is quite expensive. And did you not buy a tallis for your wedding?"
而且，读着一百年前寄过大洋的明信片里那充满罪恶感的劝诫，让我感到心里暖暖的。你只能对家人写那样的话。血缘给了你提出某些要求、以某种也许不该有的方式做自己的许可。引用：“你想让我寄给你一条犹太祈祷披巾（tallis）去美国吗？”tallis是一种祷告用的披巾。“这太难了。邮费相当贵。而且你结婚的时候没买一条吗？”
It seems possible they wrote back and forth constantly. Quote, "I am surprised that you have not received my letter. Why don't you write about your business? Mine is completely in ruin and my income is very bad." Here's what we know about Shmuel when he was writing these. He was divorced, and his two kids, he hadn't seen in years. Harry, because he was in America at 320 Cherry Street.
他们似乎经常往来回信。引用：“我很惊讶你没收到我的信。你为什么不写写你的生意？我的生意完全破产了，收入很差。”这就是我们在他写这些明信片时对什穆埃尔的了解。他离婚了，他的两个孩子，他好几年没见了。哈里因为在美国家住樱桃街320号。
His daughter was closer to home in Europe, but would never write him back. Quote, "She really does not behave like a child of mine," Shmuel writes. "For three years, I have received from her only printed Happy New Year's cards. When she came to me to invite me to her wedding, I gave her all the money she asked for and went to the wedding. She has not once written about her situation. Since childhood, as you well know, she has become a stranger to me."
他的女儿在欧洲，离家近一些，却从未回信给他。“她真的不像我生的孩子，”什穆埃尔写道。“三年来，我只收到她印的‘新年快乐’卡片。当她来请我去参加她的婚礼时，我给了她她要的所有钱，并去了婚礼。她一次也没写信告诉我她的情况。从小开始，正如你所知，她对我来说已经成了陌生人。”
Shmuel is on a kind of mission in these postcards. He seems dismayed by how scattered the family has become. And he wants to hold everyone together somehow. He writes about being lonely, having no one to have a heart to heart talk with. Quote, "Please let me know if you intend to return here with your family. Or do you want to take a pleasure trip? I would be very pleased, but the question is if you can do this without any trouble."
什穆埃尔在这些明信片里似乎肩负着某种使命。他对家庭变得如此四分五裂感到沮丧。他想以某种方式把大家聚在一起。他写到自己的孤独，没有人可以进行交心的谈话。引用：“如果你打算带着家人回这里，请告诉我。或者你想来旅行？我会很高兴，但问题是你能不能毫无麻烦地做到。”
In the map of our family, Shmuel is pretty far removed. He's like Pluto out there on a distant orbit. But I felt some tug on me. He asks after my great, great grandfather, who is living nearby in Newark, New Jersey. Quote, "Please write to me about my brother. How is he? He doesn't write to me at all. How are his children? Are they well?"
在我们家族的地图上，什穆埃尔离得很远。他就像冥王星一样，处于遥远的轨道上。但我感到某种牵动。他打听住在附近新泽西州纽瓦克的曾曾祖父的情况。引用：“请写信告诉我我兄弟的事。他好吗？他根本不给我写信。他的孩子们怎么样？他们身体好吗？”
I was struck by how consistently miserable he seems. Miserable, but also like he hasn't given up hope. He yearns for the family, wants to be with them again. I wondered if it would happen. When Harry's first son gets a little older, Shmuel writes, "Maybe it would be possible for you to send him to me, and I could fulfill the commandment and teach our children and your son's children, as my son's sons are as my own. Your father, Shmuel."
他那种一贯的悲惨感让我印象深刻。悲惨，但看起来他并没有放弃希望。他渴望家人，想再和他们在一起。我不知道这是否会发生。当哈里的第一个儿子长大一点时，什穆埃尔写道：“也许你能把他送给我，让我能尽到诫命，教导我们的孩子和你儿子的孩子，因为我儿子的儿子就是我自己的孙子。你的父亲，什穆埃尔。”
There are all these grandkids being born that he wants to see. When Harry has a daughter and names her after his grandmother, Shmuel writes, "My dear son, you have done very well. You have added the name of my dear mother. I have great joy from this."
有这么多孙辈出生，他想见他们。当哈里生了个女儿，并用他祖母的名字命名时，什穆埃尔写道：“我亲爱的儿子，你做得很好。你加上了我亲爱的母亲的名字。这让我倍感欣慰。”
But there's also this heartbreaking one. Quote, "At the end of your letter, you didn't send greetings from your son, Yitzchak, which worries me very much. Please disclose the truth to me. May we only hear good tidings." Yitzchak had died of pneumonia at age one.
但也有令人心碎的一封。引用：“在你信的末尾，你没有传达你儿子伊扎克（Yitzchak）的问候，这让我非常担心。请向我透露真相。愿我们只听到好消息。”伊扎克一岁时死于肺炎。
There's one postcard where Shmuel seems truly joyful, like he finally had a really good day or something. September 12, 1907. The entire postcard is a blessing that he composed himself in Hebrew. The translator was really struck by the poetry of it. "May the rays of your good fortune shine on your head, and may you always be a fulfilled person, love and peace in your home, all of you healthy and complete, your tents free of fear, blessings nested in your house, and success shedding its light around you."
有一张明信片什穆埃尔看起来非常快乐，就像他终于有了非常好的一天。1907年9月12日。整张明信片是他自己用希伯来语创作的祝福语。翻译人员对它的诗意印象深刻。“愿你运势的光芒照耀在你头上，愿你永远是一个知足的人，家中充满爱与和平，你们所有人都健康完整，你们的帐篷无所畏惧，祝福筑巢在你们的屋檐下，成功的光芒环绕着你们。”
But making my way through the stack of postcards, one thing after another seems to go wrong. He eventually does make contact with his daughter, Harry's sister, and visits her, but he still seems worried. Quote, "I hope there will be peace for some time." He writes about a fire that cost him a lot of money, a dealer he sends cotton wool to, goes bankrupt. Quote, "Business is very bad, as credit has been stopped, and many people have gone bankrupt. Thank God the fear of war has passed. May God bring us better times." That postcard was from May 27, 1913. When I read it, I was like, wait, what do you mean the fear of war has passed? Isn't World War I about to happen?
但在我读完这叠明信片的过程中，事情一件接一件地出错。他最终联系上了他的女儿，也就是哈里的妹妹，并去看望了她，但他依然感到担心。引用：“我希望会有和平一段时间。”他写到一场让他损失惨重的大火，他寄给一个经销商的羊毛让他破产了。引用：“生意非常糟糕，因为信贷已停止，许多人破产了。感谢上帝，战争的恐惧已经过去。愿上帝带给我们更好的时代。”那张明信片是1913年5月27日寄出的。当我读到它时，我想，等等，你说战争的恐惧已经过去是什么意思？一战不是快要爆发了吗？
Here's a postcard from a little later. The stamp had been removed, so some words are missing. But this part was intact. Quote, "The Russians plundered. We went on foot. Therefore, we took nothing with us. We were like a herd. We closed the house and left everything. We left all our property. Everything was plundered, and the house was destroyed. May God give us strength and harden our body. Is this our fate? Instead of sleeping in our bed, we slept on the ground." That postcard was sent from a town 60 miles from his home.
这是一张稍晚一点的明信片。邮票被撕掉了，所以有些字缺失。但这部分是完整的。引用：“俄国人掠夺了。我们是步行逃走的。因此，我们什么都没带。我们像一群牲畜。我们锁上了房子，丢下了一切。我们留下了所有财产。一切都被掠夺，房子被毁了。愿上帝赐予我们力量并坚硬我们的身体。这是我们的命运吗？我们本应睡在床上，现在却睡在地上。”那张明信片是从离他家60英里外的一个小镇寄出的。
There's a big gap after this. The next postcards are from years later. He's back in the town where he started. Quote, "I received the package you sent. It contained two pairs of trousers, two pairs of underpants, four undershirts, one skullcap, one napkin. I can't know if anything is missing since I don't have a list of its contents. The Lord will reward you for the mitzvah of honoring our father. And your reward will be great." This was postcard number 27 of 30. There weren't many left.
之后有一个巨大的空白。接下来的明信片是几年后的了。他回到了他开始居住的小镇。引用：“我收到了你寄来的包裹。里面有两条裤子，两条内裤，四件背心，一个圆顶小帽，一条餐巾。我不知道是否缺了什么，因为我没有内容清单。上帝会奖励你履行孝敬父亲之美德的善行。你的奖赏将是丰厚的。”这是30张明信片中的第27张。没剩下多少了。
Shmuel writes that he had heard that Harry might make a trip back home. Quote, "This would give me much joy," he writes. And also, "Do you have papers for my journey to America?" I was excited that they might all get together, but postcard 29 doesn't mention any travel plans. Quote, "It's been three months since I have written you. I am desperate not to have received an answer. This is very unusual. Please write immediately." The last postcard, number 30, is about a prayer shawl. And that's it.
什穆埃尔写道，他听说哈里可能会回家一趟。“这会让我非常高兴，”他写道。还有，“你有给我去美国的旅行证件吗？”我很高兴他们可能团聚，但第29张明信片没有提到任何旅行计划。引用：“我给你写信已经三个月了。没收到回信让我感到绝望。这非常不寻常。请立即回信。”最后一张，第30张，是关于祷告披巾的。就这样结束了。
Shmuel Mendel Kestenbaum died some time after that. He was probably 69 or 70 years old. Reading along, I was somehow stupidly expecting a happy ending. But I don't think there was one for him. It doesn't seem like Shmuel ever got to see his son again after he left at the age of 20 or got to meet Harry's kids, his grandchildren. And just that idea that you could spend so much of your life waiting for a thing to happen, and then one day, you don't even know it's coming, but it's your last day. And it never does.
什穆埃尔·门德尔·克斯滕鲍姆在那之后不久去世了。他当时可能69或70岁。读着这些，我不知为何愚蠢地期待着一个圆满的结局。但我认为他并没有。什穆埃尔似乎在哈里20岁离开后就再也没见过他，也没见过哈里的孩子们，他的孙辈。仅仅是这种想法——你可以花大半辈子等待一件事发生，而有一天，你甚至不知道它即将来临，但那却是你生命中的最后一天。而且这件事永远不会发生。
I do feel some connection to Shmuel. I'm not sure I really understand it. You could say it's because we're related by blood. It certainly is a strange experience to read your own last name on a 100-year-old postcard. It sticks with you-- Shmuel Kestenbaum. I keep thinking about the postcards. In them, Shmuel never writes about the past. He's always asking about the people who will come after him-- his son, his daughter, their kids. he cared about the future. I do, too. I care more going forward than backward. There is a happy ending to Shmuel's story. It just came much later. It's me and all the family and the giant tree that grew around him.
我确实感觉到与什穆埃尔的某种联系。我不确定我是否真正理解它。你可以说是因为我们有血缘关系。在100年前的明信片上读到自己的姓氏，这确实是一种奇怪的经历。它一直缠绕着你——什穆埃尔·克斯滕鲍姆。我一直在想这些明信片。在明信片里，什穆埃尔从不写过去的事。他总是询问那些将要来的人——他的儿子，他的女儿，他们的孩子们。他在意未来。我也一样。我更在意向前看而不是向后看。什穆埃尔的故事有一个圆满的结局。它只是来得晚了些。那结局就是我，还有所有的家人，以及在他周围生长起来的巨大参天大树。
David Kestenbaum is our show's senior editor. Coming up, one of the greatest deployments of fake blood in the history of fake blood. Also, fixing a human blood pump and a fibroid speaks in English. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
大卫·克斯滕鲍姆是我们节目的资深编辑。接下来，历史上最伟大的“假血”使用场景之一。此外，修复人体血液泵和子宫肌瘤会说英语。离我们节目继续还有一分钟，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Bloody Feelings, stories about blood in all its liquidy meanings, blood as metaphor, blood as the actual stuff moving through our veins. We've arrived at act three of our show. Act Three, Stage Fright.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是《血色感受》，讲述血液在所有液态含义下的故事，作为隐喻的血液，以及在我们血管中实际流动的物质。我们进入节目的第三幕。第三幕，“舞台恐惧”。
So there's this condition. It's called vasovagal syncope. And it's basically fainting in reaction to certain stimuli. It's triggered by all kinds of things-- exposure to heat, stress, and the sight of blood. And it turns out that the blood, it doesn't even need to be real blood to get that response. One of our producers, Bim Adewunmi, remembers one bloody Shakespeare production that, at its height, had scores of people fainting, night after night. Here's Bim.
有一种病，叫血管迷走性晕厥。它基本上就是由于对特定刺激的反应而导致的昏厥。它由各种事物触发——暴露于高温、压力和看到血液。事实证明，甚至不需要是真实的血液就能产生那种反应。我们的一位制片人比姆·阿德温米（Bim Adewunmi）记得一场血腥的莎士比亚演出，在最高潮时，每晚都有许多人昏倒。下面请听比姆的报道。
Back in 2006, I was a year out of university, trying very hard to be a writer and working at a bookshop in central London. I was also almost always broke, so broke, in fact, that I don't think I could afford more than one visit to see a West End show the entire year. What I did do a lot of, though, was read theater reviews. 2006 was the year of Michael Sheen and Frank Langella in Frost/Nixon. It was the year Avenue Q came to the West End, the year of Wicked's London debut. And all I could do was dream of going to see them.
2006年，我刚大学毕业一年，非常努力地想成为一名作家，并在伦敦市中心的一家书店工作。我几乎总是身无分文，穷到什么地步呢？我想我一年连去西区看一场戏的钱都拿不出。但我做的一件事是读戏剧评论。2006年是迈克尔·辛和弗兰克·兰格拉主演《福斯特/尼克松》的那一年。那是《Q大道》来到西区的一年，是《魔法坏女巫》伦敦首演的那年。而我唯一能做的就是梦想着去看看。
So naturally, the review page was the first place I read about a play that was getting rave reviews, but was apparently so grisly, so bloody, audience members were fainting. The play was one of Shakespeare's least loved plays, Titus Andronicus, three hours of muscular, bloody theater that, as one audience member quoted in the paper put it, had people "dropping like flies." I was thrilled at the idea of theater being powerful enough to fell even sturdy London theatergoers. I was jealous. I wanted to go. I wanted to see if I could withstand it. In the 15 years since, I've often thought about the source of that production's power-- about the blood.
所以自然地，评论版是我读到的关于一部戏的第一来源，那部戏好评如潮，但显然太可怕、太血腥了，观众们纷纷晕倒。这部戏是莎士比亚最不受欢迎的作品之一，《泰特斯·安特洛尼克斯》，整整三个小时肌肉横飞、血腥暴力的戏剧，正如报纸引用的一位观众所说，它让人们“像苍蝇一样倒下”。我对那种足以让坚强的伦敦剧迷都为之倾倒的戏剧力量感到兴奋。我嫉妒。我想去。我想看看自己是否能抵挡得住。在过去的15年里，我经常思考那部戏力量的源泉——关于血液。
I mean, at one point, we had 43 people, one show, 43 people fainted.
我的意思是，有一次，我们在同一场演出中有43个人昏倒。
43?
43个？
That was our max.
那是我们的最高纪录。
All these years later, I was thrilled to talk to the director, Lucy Bailey. Because I wanted to understand how she'd done something so extraordinary.
多年后的今天，我非常高兴能采访到导演露西·贝利（Lucy Bailey）。因为我想了解她是如何创造出如此非凡的事物的。
Once I came into the auditorium and the usher said, all the schoolgirls came and they all fainted.
有一次我走进礼堂，引座员说，所有的女中学生都来了，她们全都昏倒了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And they're all in this box. We put them all up there. So I came in, looked in the room, and all these sort of very pale girls, all sitting there, [LAUGHS] having been fainted and being taken out. I used to say to the ushers when I came into see the show, and how many people today?
她们都在包厢里。我们把她们都放在那儿。所以我走进去，看了看房间，所有那些脸色苍白的女孩都坐在那儿，[笑]昏倒过，被抬了出来。我过去常对引座员说，今天有多少人？
Just to be clear-- no one fell and hit their head or got seriously injured. They were simply overwhelmed. Lucy just hadn't foreseen the fainting. To give you a picture, the Globe is an open-air theater, a mostly faithful recreation of Shakespeare's original, with just under half of its audience standing close to the action on the stage. And the Globe is used to fainters-- the combination of standing and the sun probably. During Titus, when a person fainted, the ushers would wind through the crowd with an unfolded wheelchair and then take them out of the arena. Later in the run, there was a St. John's ambulance parked nearby.
澄清一下——没有人摔倒磕到头或受重伤。他们只是被震撼了。露西只是没预料到会出现晕厥。为了给你们一个画面：环球剧院是一个露天剧院，是对莎士比亚原版剧院最忠实的复刻，不到一半的观众站在离舞台很近的地方。环球剧院也习惯了人们晕倒——大概是因为站立和阳光的结合。在《泰特斯》演出期间，当有人晕倒时，引座员会穿过人群，推着折叠轮椅将他们抬出竞技场。在演出后半段，附近还停了一辆圣约翰救护车。
It's not surprising. The blood in context and in quantity is inescapable. And it's supposed to be. Titus Andronicus is one of Shakespeare's earliest plays. And there's a lot of young man swagger mixed in with the poetry of the writing. Set in ancient Rome, the play was written to speak to some of the fascinations of the Elizabethan era. It's about war and revenge and an over-the-top grief that clouds good sense and moderation. Innocents get slain. Brutes revel in their savagery.
这并不奇怪。在那种背景下，血液的数量是无法逃避的。而这正是刻意的。《泰特斯·安特洛尼克斯》是莎士比亚最早期的剧作之一。在写作的诗意中混合了许多年轻人的狂傲。故事设定在古罗马，创作的目的是为了迎合伊丽莎白时代的某些嗜好。它是关于战争、复仇，以及一种掩盖了理智与节制的过度悲伤。无辜者被杀戮。野蛮人在他们的残暴中纵情狂欢。
Blood is shed in really horrible ways-- ritual sacrifice, slit throats, mutilation, sexual assault, plus a memorable cannibalistic pie. It's a play that's drenched in blood. And it often gets written off as a flurry of unsubstantial bloodlettings because of that. But Lucy knew the blood mattered to the play. One of the first things she had to figure out was how to make the blood look real. In an ironic twist, to make the blood look like the real thing, they had to fake it.
血液以非常可怕的方式流淌——仪式祭祀、割喉、肢解、性侵，还有一个令人难忘的食人肉派。这是一部浸透在血泊中的剧作。正因为如此，它经常被写成是一连串毫无内涵的流血事件。但露西知道血液对这部戏至关重要。她需要弄清楚的第一件事是如何让血看起来真实。讽刺的是，为了让血看起来像真的，他们必须使用假血。
If you see a lot of stage blood, it often doesn't feel very real, even if it's quite accurate, the color of blood. But blood is quite bright. And somehow that bright blood in theater terms makes you go, oh, yeah, yeah, that's just theater blood. We sort of looked at how we would make it unreal in order to make it more real. In other words, we darkened the blood.
如果你看到很多舞台血，它们通常感觉不太真实，即使颜色和血液很像。但血液是非常明亮的。不知为何，在戏剧里，这种明亮的血液会让你觉得，哦，对，那只是戏剧血。为了让它更真实，我们研究了如何让它看起来不那么“假”。换句话说，我们把血液加深了颜色。
Lucy also had to figure out how to make the blood move so it would deliver the most impact. So she turned to another expert-- the fight director.
露西还必须弄清楚如何让血液流动，以产生最大的冲击力。所以她转向了另一位专家——动作指导。
You talk to him about if you're wounded in this way, how does the blood behave? Where does the blood come? Why is it coming out of the corner of the mouth? Why is it coming from the nose? What's the journey of the blood?
你和他商量：如果这样被刺伤，血液会怎么表现？血从哪里流出？为什么是从嘴角流出来？为什么是从鼻子里？血液的流动路径是什么？
For Tamara, who the audience love to hate, there's a very careful spurt of blood when she gets a giant fork in the guts. When Titus loses a hand, there was more than one source of blood, a spurt from a syringe, then a slower ooze out of his arm. To make the intense experience more immersive, Lucy and her designer, Bill Dudley, focused on the space itself. They wanted to make it feel oppressive, make the audience participate in the blood sport.
对于塔摩拉，这个观众爱恨交加的角色，当她腹部被刺入巨叉时，有一股非常小心的喷血。当泰特斯失去一只手时，血液来源不止一处，从注射器喷出，然后从他的手臂缓缓溢出。为了让这种强烈的体验更具沉浸感，露西和她的设计师比尔·达德利（Bill Dudley）专注于空间本身。他们想营造出压抑感，让观众参与到这场血腥运动中。
They achieved this by giving the Globe a temporary velarium roof, which reduced the sunlight and created shadows. And then they filled the space with incense. They moved some of the action off the stage and into the crowd to create a sort of theater of chance. The idea was to make it feel like a temple of death. They have to strike a delicate balance-- too little blood and atmosphere, and you don't bring the audience along. Too much, and it feels like a parody.
他们通过给环球剧院搭建一个临时的顶棚（velarium roof）来实现这一点，这减少了阳光并制造了阴影。然后他们在空间中充满了香气。他们将一些动作从舞台移到观众席中，创造了一种“机缘戏剧”。这个想法是为了让它感觉像一座死亡神殿。他们必须在微妙的平衡中游走——过少的血和氛围，观众就无法被带入；太多，又感觉像是一种模仿。
It's like a huge contract, isn't it, between the audience and the play and the players. The audience, given any chance, want to believe. So as long as you do everything to suspend the disbelief, then you keep that contract. But as soon as you break that contract and do something that shows them the mechanics or overacts, overplays your cards, over-eggs it, too much blood or under-eggs it, too little blood at the moment, where they're going, sorry, I don't believe that.
这就像一份巨大的契约，不是吗？观众、戏剧和演员之间。只要给任何机会，观众都想相信。所以只要你竭尽全力维持那种真实感，你就能维持那份契约。但一旦你打破契约，做了任何暴露出制作机制的事情，或者表演过火、牌打得太满，或者过分渲染、血流太多，或者处理不到位，太少，观众就会说，对不起，我不相信。
And one of the places they decided to underplay happens in the very first bloodletting in the play, when Titus sacrifices Alarbus.
而他们决定“轻处理”的地方之一，发生在剧中的第一次流血场面，当时泰特斯祭祀了阿拉伯斯（Alarbus）。
It happened very quickly in how we did it. And it was so fast. And then they saw the blood. And then we're pulling him, and they don't have time to dwell. So we did a very deliberate thing. We really were shocking with it.
这一幕我们处理得非常快。非常快。然后他们看到了血。然后我们就把他拖走了，他们没时间多想。所以我们做了一件非常刻意的事情。我们真的用它制造了震撼。
The audience sees a flash of red, and then he's gone almost immediately. Maybe the blood made them faint, but it wasn't just the fact of it that caused them to fall. It was what was happening between the people on stage, the feelings they were experiencing. One of the most shattering moments in the play comes after Lavinia, attacked and mutilated, is brought to her father and unwrapped. The dark viscous blood seeps through the bandages at her stumps and pours slowly from her mouth. Even Titus, a war-hardened general who's done his own share of killing, is reduced in that moment to an anguished and helpless father.
观众看到一抹红色闪过，然后他几乎立刻就消失了。也许血让观众昏倒了，但导致他们倒下的不仅仅是那件事实本身。而是舞台上人们之间发生的事情，他们正在经历的感受。剧中破碎感最强的一刻出现在拉维妮娅（Lavinia）被攻击、肢解，被带到她父亲面前打开包裹时。深红色的粘稠血液渗过断肢处的绷带，缓慢地从她嘴里涌出。即便是泰特斯，这位身经百战、杀戮无数的将军，在那一刻也变成了一个痛苦而无助的父亲。
His precious daughter still bleeds, and he can't stop that bleeding. To have your life's blood bleed, your kin, the blood that is your blood, and to see it bleeding and to understand how those wounds were made pushes the brain to a point of madness.
他珍贵的女儿依然在流血，而他却无法阻止那种流血。看到你生命之血在流失，你的亲人，那和你血脉相连的血液，看到它在流血，并理解这些伤口是如何造成的，会将大脑推向疯狂的边缘。
As Titus himself says in that scene, it was my dear, and he that wounded her have hurt me more than had he killed me dead.
正如泰特斯本人在那一幕中所说，那是我的珍宝，而伤害她的人比杀了我更让我痛苦。
It's a girl who's still alive, but bleeding and causes so much internal bleeding to her father, both in the heart and the brain. So, in a way, he suffers a kind of brain bleed.
这是一个依然活着但在流血的女孩，这给她父亲造成了巨大的内出血，无论是在心脏还是大脑中。所以，某种程度上，他遭受了一种“脑出血”。
The entire play is tied together by that ribbon of grief. Parents lose children. Brothers turn on each other. Innocent bystanders are collateral damage. And all the blood is in the service of that raw feeling. The language is hysterical and violent. And it goes on for five long acts. The audience gets pulled into the hysteria because they have little choice. By the halfway point in Act Three, they're so far gone that they drop at the idea of violence.
整部戏都被那一根悲伤的丝带串联起来。父母失去了孩子。兄弟反目成仇。无辜的旁观者成了附带损害。所有的血液都是为了服务于那种原始的感觉。语言既歇斯底里又充满暴力。而且持续了五个漫长的幕。观众因为别无选择而被卷入这种歇斯底里。到了第三幕中点时，他们已经陷得太深，以至于一听到暴力这个念头就会倒下。
We used to have people fainting on a word. So when Aaron came and said that he wanted one of them to chop off their hand, you could almost guarantee that somebody would faint when he said chop.
我们过去常有观众听到一个字就昏倒。所以当亚伦（Aaron）走出来说他想要他们中的一个人砍掉自己的手时，你可以保证当他说出“砍”字时，一定会有人昏倒。
When Aaron says the word here, there's no actual chopping happening-- he's just saying it. But it was enough.
当亚伦在这里说这个词时，并没有实际的砍伐动作——他只是说了出来。但这就足够了。
You could see the audience sort of gird themselves. And then he'd say chop, and somebody would go.
你能看到观众那种紧绷的状态。然后他说“砍”，就有人倒下了。
One of the things I was curious to talk to Lucy about was how it felt to be the architect of all this feeling. What was it like to do this to an audience again and again?
我好奇想和露西谈论的事情之一是，作为这种情感的建筑师是什么感觉。一遍又一遍地对观众做这种事是什么体验？
I have to be honest, it was completely thrilling. We had not expected this response. Audiences tend not to be vocal, so this kind of fainting was a sort of sign of audience involvement, I think. I think the whole effect to see the astonishing effect it had on people to the extent that people were sick, they fainted-- they even urinated. They lost control of--
老实说，这非常令人激动。我们完全没有预料到这种反应。观众通常不喜欢出声，所以这种昏倒是一种观众参与的标志，我想。我认为这种令人惊讶的效果——人们呕吐、晕倒——他们甚至尿了。他们失去了对——
Wow.
哇。
--their whole body, was to do with this cumulative feeling, a combination of things, not just one thing. It was such an affirmation that something about the play was working.
——整个身体的控制，与这种累积的情感有关，是各种事物的组合，不仅仅是一件事。这是对这部戏的某种东西正在起作用的一种有力肯定。
Eight years after that first production in 2014, Lucy revived Titus Andronicus at the Globe. It was a different cast. And once again, audiences flocked to see this difficult, bloody play. This time, though--
2014年，距离2006年的首演八年后，露西在环球剧院复排了《泰特斯·安特洛尼克斯》。那是不同的演员班底。再一次，观众蜂拥而至观看这部困难、血腥的戏。然而这一次——
The audience didn't faint as much. I mean, they really didn't. And yet, everything we did was, I think, palpably the same, if not better. And I think that was because people came psychologically prepared. So it was very much harder to get that contract going that you're so involved in this that you're going to faint.
观众没那么频繁地昏倒了。我是说，真的没有。然而，我认为我们所做的一切，如果不是更好的话，也肯定是同样的震撼。我想那是因为人们在心理上有了准备。所以要建立那种“你沉浸其中以至于昏倒”的契约变得非常困难。
Modern theater is mostly a quiet affair-- polite applause, gentle chuckles. Usually when people leave a play in the middle of a performance is because it's bad. They're not feeling what they're supposed to be feeling. With Titus, they were checking out because they were feeling too much.
现代戏剧大多是安静的事务——礼貌的掌声，轻轻的笑声。通常人们在演出中途离场是因为戏演得烂。他们没有感受到他们应该感受到的东西。而在《泰特斯》中，他们离场是因为感受得太多了。
Bim Adewunmi is one of the producers of our show.
比姆·阿德温米是我们节目的制片人之一。
Act Four, There's No Us in Uterus-- Oh, Wait. So about 30 million Americans have fibroids. And if you don't know what this is, fibroids are these muscular tumors that grow on or in the uterus. We don't know what causes them or why they affect people of color at higher rates, especially Black people. In fact, we know so little about them that Vice President Kamala Harris introduced the Uterine Fibroid Research and Education Act last August back when she was still senator.
第四幕，“子宫里没有‘我们’——噢，等等”。大约有3000万美国人患有子宫肌瘤。如果你不知道这是什么，肌瘤就是生长在子宫壁上或子宫内的肌肉肿瘤。我们不知道是什么导致了它们，也不知道为什么它们在有色人种中发病率更高，尤其是黑人。事实上，我们对它们的了解太少了，以至于副总统卡玛拉·哈里斯（Kamala Harris）在去年8月，当她还是参议员时，就提出了《子宫肌瘤研究与教育法案》。
Almost always, fibroids are benign. Like, they don't turn into cancer. But they still cause problems-- pain, discomfort, and then there's the blood, which, of course, is what our program is about today. Fibroids can make periods heavier or longer or more erratic. Doctors can be dismissive. Surgery's expensive and carries risks. And even after surgery, fibroids can come back, new ones.
几乎所有的肌瘤都是良性的。比如，它们不会转化为癌症。但它们依然会引起问题——疼痛、不适，还有出血，这当然是我们今天节目的主题。肌瘤会使经期变重、变长或更不规律。医生可能会不予理睬。手术很昂贵且存在风险。即使手术后，肌瘤也可能复发，新的会长出来。
Neena Pathak went back and forth about getting surgery. Her fibroid didn't bother her at first, but over time, it grew bigger and caused more and more discomfort. And she began to think about her fibroid like a careless partner, making her life miserable. She even imagined confronting the fibroid, in the relative safety of a therapist's office, with a question-- should we stay together? She made this into a one-act play starring three characters-- woman, fibroid, and therapist. And we present now the world premiere of her play.
妮娜·帕塔克（Neena Pathak）对于是否动手术犹豫不决。她的肌瘤起初并不困扰她，但随着时间推移，它越长越大，造成了越来越多的不适。她开始把她的肌瘤想象成一个粗心的伴侣，让她的生活变得痛苦。她甚至想象在心理咨询师办公室相对安全的空间里，面对肌瘤，提出了一个问题——我们还应该在一起吗？她把这做成了一个一幕剧，主角有三个：女人、肌瘤和咨询师。现在我们呈现她这部剧的世界首演。
Well, then, let's get started. Tell me why you're here today.
好了，让我们开始吧。告诉我在今天为什么来这儿。
Mm, like I had a choice. She dragged me here.
嗯，就像我有的选一样。是她硬拖我来的。
Don't be an ass. Please?
别混蛋。拜托？
I'm not. I'm a fibroid.
我没混蛋。我只是个肌瘤。
Talk to her.
对她说。
OK. We only ever do what you want to do. You dragged me here.
行。我们总是只做你想做的事。是你硬拖我来的。
Well, I'm just trying to figure out whether we should be together anymore.
好吧，我只是想弄清楚我们是否还应该在一起。
You told me I could stay with you.
是你告诉我我可以和你待在一起的。
Told you, you could stay with me? You never even asked!
告诉你可以和我待在一起？你从来没问过！
I want you both to try making I statements.
我希望你们都能尝试使用“我”陈述句。
I was told that I could stay with-- wait, can I not say you at all if I'm making an I statement?
我被告知我可以待在——等等，如果我使用“我”陈述句，我完全不能用“你”这个字吗？
You're doing fine. Would you like to respond?
你做得很好。你想回应吗？
I mean, at first it wasn't so bad. I barely noticed you, to be honest. So I didn't really mind that you were around. But then your pile of stuff just kept getting bigger and bigger. I just-- I felt steamrolled. And now you act like you own the place.
我的意思是，起初没那么糟糕。老实说，我几乎没注意到你。所以我真的不在意你在身边。但后来你的东西越堆越多。我只是——我觉得被碾压了。现在你表现得好像你拥有这个地方。
Like I own the place? I have one small room where I keep my things, one bloody room. Everything I eat, everything I breathe, it's all yours. All you. And I certainly don't appreciate you relitigating the past.
好像我拥有这个地方？我只有一个存放东西的小房间，一个血淋淋的房间。我吃的一切，我呼吸的一切，全都是你的。全都是你的。而且我当然不赞成你翻旧账。
What do you mean, relitigating the past?
你说的翻旧账是什么意思？
I mean, I have already apologized for this. I'm sorry I moved in without your explicit permission. You never said it was bothering you, so I just assumed it was OK. But I can't keep apologizing over and over for something I can't undo.
我的意思是，我已经为这件事道过歉了。很抱歉我没经过你的明确许可就搬进来了。你从来没说这让你感到困扰，所以我以为没关系。但我不能为了无法撤销的事情一遍又一遍地道歉。
I just-- I did say it was bothering me. You just didn't listen. And I'm not asking you to apologize over and over. I mean, I'm pretty easygoing. I don't like making a big deal out of stuff. I'm 35 years old. Isn't this kind of what being a grown-up is all about? When things don't go my way, I suck it up, you know? Roll with the punches. And honestly, I could still live my life.
我只是——我确实说过这让我困扰。只是你没听。而且我没要求你一遍又一遍地道歉。我的意思是，我挺随和的。我不喜欢把事情闹大。我35岁了。这不就是成年人的生活吗？当事情不顺我的意时，我只能忍着，你知道吗？随遇而安。坦白说，我依然能过我的生活。
Remind me then, what brings you here today?
那么提醒我一下，今天是什么事带你们来这儿的？
Well, I mean, I'm fed up. You take up more space every day. You damage my property. You're totally oblivious to how your actions affect anyone but you.
好吧，我的意思是，我受够了。你每天占据更多的空间。你损坏了我的财产。你对你的行为如何影响除你之外的人完全一无所知。
OK, you know what? Fine. Try and kick me out then. And look, I wasn't going to bring this up, but someone has to-- I thought you wanted kids. Surgery is serious business, you know? What if it doesn't work? There's a chance you could lose your uterus. There's a chance you could never have a baby. There's a chance you could die. Just putting that out there.
好吧，你知道吗？行。那就试着把我踢出去啊。你看，我本来不想提这个，但总得有人说——我以为你想要孩子。手术可是大事，你知道吗？如果失败了怎么办？你有可能会失去子宫。你有可能永远怀不了孩子。你有可能死掉。只是抛出这些可能性而已。
A slim chance. And thanks.
几率很小。谢谢。
That stuff happens. Just saying.
那种事确实会发生。只是说说而已。
I don't know if I want kids. But if I do, I think having them without you would be a better option.
我不知道我是否想要孩子。但如果我想要，我想没有你在，那会是更好的选择。
Have you gotten yourself checked out?
你检查过身体了吗？
Well, I've talked to some specialists, but they mostly just told me not to worry, that this situation's harmless.
我咨询过一些专家，但他们大多数只告诉我不用担心，这种情况无害。
The experts agree you're making a big deal over nothing.
专家们一致认为你在小题大做。
That's the thing. It's not nothing. It's like, I used to be fun. Now I'm this compressed anemic version of myself. Because I'm always thinking about you. I'm always planning around you, never sure when you're going to open the floodgates.
关键就在这儿。这不是无害。我的意思是，我过去很有活力。现在我是一个被压缩的贫血版本的自己。因为我总是想着你。我总是围绕着你做计划，从来不确定你什么时候会打开“洪水之门”。
The bloodgates.
“血之门”。
That's not funny.
一点都不好笑。
There will be blood.
血一定会流出来的。
Let's take a deep breath. I want you to look at each other.
让我们深呼吸。我要你们看着对方。
Ugh.
呃。
Just work with me here. One at a time. Is there something one of you wants to say that you haven't yet said?
配合我一下。一个一个来。有什么你们想说却还没说出口的话吗？
Mm, yeah. What we have, it's not so bad. No relationship is perfect. Sure, we have some unpleasant little blowups every month, but you know what else is unpleasant every month? Paying rent. Doing laundry is unpleasant, and that's once a week. Doing dishes every day, unpleasant. But that's life, baby. Could be worse. And very well may be worse without me. As they say, it's the fibroid you know. Do you really want to be 35 and alone?
嗯，有。我们现在这样，没那么糟糕。没有哪段关系是完美的。当然，我们每个月会有一些不愉快的小爆发，但你知道每个月还有什么是不愉快的吗？交房租。洗衣服是不愉快的，那每周一次。每天洗碗，不愉快。但这才是生活，宝贝。可能会更糟。而且没有我，情况很可能会更糟。俗话说，宁要你认识的肌瘤（指熟悉的问题胜过不确定的）。你真的想35岁孤身一人吗？
OK, no. I think I've been lying to myself and pretending that everything's OK. And I know you say it could be worse, but it could be better. That's why I want you out. I'm kicking you out.
好了，不。我想我一直都在骗自己，假装一切都好。我知道你说可能会更糟，但它也可能变得更好。这就是为什么我要你走。我要把你踢出去。
But it can't possibly be worth the risk.
但这绝不可能值得冒险。
Well, I don't know what else to tell you. I just, I need to try. And you miss 100% of the shots that you don't take.
好吧，我不知道还能告诉你什么。我只是，我必须尝试一下。而且你不去尝试，永远不会成功。
Oh, god, I hate when you do that voice.
天哪，我讨厌你用那种语气说话。
Absence makes the heart grow fonder.
距离产生美。
Jesus Christ.
上帝啊。
Be the change you wish to see in the world.
成为你想在世界上看到的改变。
Oh, come on. You don't know what life will be like without me.
噢，得了吧。你根本不知道没有我会是什么样的生活。
Oh my god. I'm going to wear white pants again.
天哪。我又可以穿白色裤子了。
The woman was played by Sohina Sidhu, the fibroid by Kate Arrington, and the therapist by Jena Friedman. Casting help from Harrison Nesbit. Neena Pathak wrote this play in part at the Third Coast Radio Residency at Ragdale. Neena, by the way, in real life decided to have her fibroid removed, and she's doing fine.
女人由索希娜·西杜（Sohina Sidhu）饰演，肌瘤由凯特·阿灵顿（Kate Arrington）饰演，心理咨询师由珍娜·弗里德曼（Jena Friedman）饰演。选角帮助来自哈里森·内斯比特（Harrison Nesbit）。妮娜·帕塔克的部分剧本创作于拉格代尔（Ragdale）的第三方海岸广播驻地。顺便说一句，现实生活中的妮娜决定摘除肌瘤，她现在感觉很好。
Act Five, Unbreak My Heart. So for our last story about blood today, we go right to the source, the machine that keeps blood pumping and flowing inside of us, and to somebody whose job it is to make sure that machine works well. Producer Sean Cole talked to this man and also watched him work. A warning-- if you are squamous about people's insides, this story has a lot of that.
第五幕，“修补我破碎的心”。今天关于血液的最后一个故事，我们直接来到源头——那个保持血液在我们体内泵送和流动的机器，以及那些确保机器正常工作的人。制片人肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）与这个人谈话，并观察了他的工作。警告——如果你对人体内部结构感到反胃，这个故事有很多相关描写。
My favorite fun fact about blood is that it has a protein in it that's also found in eggs-- albumin. Something about that just strikes me as poetic-- the complex machine of the human body and a thing it eats for breakfast sharing the same ingredient. I learned about this fact from a heart surgeon, Dr. John Elefteriades, or Dr. E.
关于血液我最喜欢的一个趣事是，它含有的一种蛋白质在鸡蛋中也能找到——白蛋白。关于这一点，有些东西让我觉得很诗意——人体复杂的机器和我们早餐吃的食物共享同一种成分。我是从一位心脏外科医生约翰·埃莱夫特里亚德斯（Dr. John Elefteriades）医生，即埃医生那里了解到的。
About five years ago, I drove up to Yale New Haven Hospital and talked with him about this one technique he employs called deep hypothermic circulatory arrest, AKA the deep freeze. Often, he has to do such radical plumbing work on the heart and its arteries that his team cools the patient's body down to 64 degrees Fahrenheit and then warms them back up again afterwards. He compares it, in one way, to making egg lemon soup. You don't want the egg to curdle.
大约五年前，我开车去耶鲁纽黑文医院，和他谈论了他使用的一项技术，叫深低温停循环（deep hypothermic circulatory arrest），即“深冻”。他经常不得不对心脏及其动脉进行非常激进的管道工作，以至于他的团队将病人的体温降至华氏64度，然后再将其回升。他把它比作制作鸡蛋蛋花汤。你不想让蛋花凝固。
And it curdles when the cook is in a hurry. It has to simmer at a very low level in order not to curdle. Well, that's because of the albumin and the egg. And the bloodstream is full of albumin. So that if we warm too fast, we'll basically get scrambled eggs in the bloodstream.
当厨师赶时间时，它就会凝固。为了不凝固，它必须保持极低水平的温度。好吧，那是白蛋白和鸡蛋的原因。而血液中充满了白蛋白。所以如果我们升温太快，血液里基本上就会变成炒鸡蛋。
That is so gross.
那太恶心了。
That's catastrophic. So warming takes one hour. We have to warm very slowly. As long as our heating bath is no more than 10 degrees warmer than the blood, the blood won't curdle. We won't get scrambled eggs.
那是灾难性的。所以升温需要一个小时。我们必须非常缓慢地升温。只要我们的加热浴液温度不超过血液温度10度，血液就不会凝固。我们不会得到炒鸡蛋。
Dr. E is an expert on this deep freeze method. He's been described as one of the best doctors in the country, a giant of cardiothoracic surgery. When we met in 2015, he'd been at Yale for more than 30 years and done about 7,000 open heart operations at that point, including maybe 300 transplants. He dramatically lengthened the lives of the jazz musician Dave Brubeck and the writer Robert Ludlum. For a long time, he did one major operation and then maybe one smaller procedure almost every weekday.
埃医生是这种深冻方法的专家。他被誉为国内最好的医生之一，是心胸外科界的泰斗。当我们2015年见面时，他在耶鲁工作了30多年，当时已经进行了大约7000例开胸手术，包括约300例移植手术。他显著延长了爵士乐手戴夫·布鲁贝克（Dave Brubeck）和作家罗伯特·勒德伦（Robert Ludlum）的生命。很长一段时间里，他几乎每个工作日都会做一台大手术，然后可能还会做一台较小的手术。
He offered to let me watch him perform the deep freeze, to watch him take a patient and literally suspend their animation. That's what cooling them down does. They're not dead, but they show no signs of life anymore. So that he could reach into their body, disconnect a crucial organ, and fix it with his hands. It's like he's a master illusionist, fooling death with this high stakes version of misdirection. I was like, yeah. Yeah, I'm in.
他让我观看他执行“深冻”，看着他让病人彻底进入“悬浮动画”状态。这就是降温的作用。他们还没死，但已经没有任何生命迹象了。这样他就能触及他们的身体，切断关键器官，并用手进行修复。就像他是一位魔术大师，用这种高风险的误导手段愚弄了死亡。我当时就想，好吧。好吧，我加入。
I was thinking that the sound of opening a breastbone might be interesting for you.
我当时在想，切开胸骨的声音可能会让你觉得很有趣。
The procedure I observed was a three-hour aortic graft and valve replacement. I got to the OR early, about 7:30 in the morning on a Thursday, all gowned up with a mask and scrub hat. The team was already prepping the patient for sedation. Dr. E and I stood several yards away in the corner so he could go over the case with me. The patient had an aortic aneurysm. You may know-- I didn't-- the aorta is the largest artery in the body and shaped like a candy cane. An aneurysm just means that part of it, the curved part at the top in this case, had become swollen, stretched, like a balloon filling with air. So the wall of it was too thin.
我观察的手术是一台耗时三个小时的主动脉移植和瓣膜置换术。我提前到了手术室，那是周四早上约7点半，穿着手术衣，戴着口罩和手术帽。团队已经在为病人进行镇静准备。埃医生和我站在角落里几码外的地方，以便他能和我过一遍病历。病人患有主动脉瘤。你可能知道——我不知道——主动脉是人体中最大的动脉，形状像拐杖糖。动脉瘤仅仅意味着它的一部分，在这个案例中是顶部弯曲的部分，已经肿胀、拉伸，就像一个充气的气球。所以它的壁太薄了。
See, unlike many other diseases, it doesn't have any symptoms until it ruptures. So the first symptom is usually a rupture or death.
看，与其他许多疾病不同，它在破裂前没有任何症状。所以第一个症状通常就是破裂或者死亡。
Death seems like it's more than a symptom.
死亡听起来似乎不仅仅是一个症状。
Yes.
是的。
It seems like it's a conclusion.
它似乎是一个结论。
It's a conclusion. Yeah, that's very well stated, yeah.
它是一个结论。是的，说得太好了。
The patient was still awake at this point, eyes wide open, listening to one of the anesthesiologists. He had a brown mustache and a beer gut, looked nervous, leaning toward afraid. Within minutes, he was unconscious. And they were painting his naked body all over with an iodine baste, taped his eyes shut, and then they swaddled him completely in plastic and blue surgical sheets, which made the whole thing feel much more impersonal. Dr. E seems to care a lot about his patients. But this is when I began to understand how automotive his work is-- managing the proper function of this motor with its valves and chambers and sparks, propelling a person's blood. Finally, they made the first incision.
病人此时还清醒，眼睛瞪得大大的，听着一位麻醉师说话。他留着棕色胡子，挺着啤酒肚，看起来很紧张，表现出害怕的样子。几分钟内，他就失去了知觉。他们用碘伏擦拭了他裸露的身体，把他的眼睛贴上胶带，然后把他完全用塑料布和蓝色手术床单包裹起来，这让整件事感觉冷冰冰的。埃医生似乎非常关心他的病人。但这也是我开始理解他的工作有多像汽车维修的时候——管理这台带有瓣膜、腔室和火花的引擎的正确功能，推动着人的血液。最后，他们做了第一刀。
And they're opening him up now and opening a femoral artery down by the pelvis. It's a lot of blood.
他们正在切开他，并在骨盆附近的股动脉进行切割。血量很多。
And Dr. E was right. The sound of them sawing open the breastbone was-- I guess we can go with alarming.
埃医生说得对。他们锯开胸骨的声音——我想我们可以说——令人不安。
[SAWING]
[锯声]
Then they inserted the chest separator. It's like a reverse vice. Instead of squeezing things together, it spreads them apart. While I watched on a wall monitor, the circulating nurse, Patty LaFond, came over and explained to me that they were slicing open the pericardium, this kind of protective sac around the heart. I didn't know it came with that extra bit of packaging.
然后他们插入了胸腔牵开器。它像一个反向的虎钳。它不是挤压，而是将其分开。当我看着墙上的监视器时，循环护士帕蒂·拉丰（Patty LaFond）走过来向我解释，他们正在切开围心膜，这是心脏周围的一种保护囊。我不知道它还附带那种额外的包装。
And is that the liver?
那是肝脏吗？
No.
不。
That big part.
那个大块的。
Lung.
肺。
That's the lung. Wow.
那是肺。哇。
You can almost see it expand and contract with breath.
你几乎能看到它随着呼吸扩张和收缩。
She was right. I watched the lungs expand and contract with this placid rhythm that made me think of ocean waves rolling in and out. It was earthly, and it was familiar. And then things got a lot more intense.
她说得对。我看着肺以一种平静的节奏扩张和收缩，这让我想起海浪起伏。那是世俗的，也是熟悉的。然后情况变得更加激烈了。
Holy crap. Holy, holy smokes. Oh, boy. Cutting tissue, cutting tissue open. Sort of like pushing the lung to the left. Now, whoa. They've broken through to the heart, which is beating. It's sort of jumping like a fish in his chest.
天哪。天哪。哦，男孩。切割组织，切开组织。有点像把肺推向左边。现在，哇。他们已经触及心脏，它还在跳动。它在胸腔里像一条鱼一样跳跃。
Like an angry fish trying violently to escape. But even that's too terrestrial a description for what this looked like. It looked alien, like a creature in a sci-fi movie with no familial relationship to humanity. It was startling, almost frightening. And I will never forget it. To think that same thing, essentially, is also inside of me and Dr. E and all of you and everyone. But when you see it, you think, that thing is not to be trusted.
就像一条愤怒的鱼在暴力逃脱。但即使那样描述对于这看起来的样子也太接地气了。它看起来像外星人，就像科幻电影里的生物，与人类没有亲缘关系。它令人震惊，近乎恐惧。我将永远不会忘记它。想到同样的东西，本质上，也存在于我、埃医生、你们所有人以及每个人体内。但当你看到它时，你会想，那东西是不可信的。
Just then, Dr. E asked me if I wanted to come up top.
就在这时，埃医生问我是否想上去看看。
Yes, please.
是的，拜托。
He meant onto the stool just behind the blue drape that separates the sterile area where they were operating from the rest of the room. So I was standing almost exactly above the patient's body, looking down into it. And being that close, this felt like I was looking at something so fundamental and ancient. And I felt like this is not something a regular schmuck like me is supposed to see. If your guts are exposed and I'm there, it usually means something's gone really wrong.
他的意思是登上蓝色帷幕后的凳子，那帷幕将他们操作的无菌区域与房间其他地方隔开。所以我就站在病人身体正上方，向下俯瞰着它。离得那么近，这感觉就像我在看某种如此根本且古老的东西。我觉得这不应该是像我这样的普通人看的东西。如果你的内脏暴露在外而我在那里，通常意味着出了大乱子。
I didn't realize that hearts were so big.
我没意识到心脏有那么大。
Now one thing I tried to convey in the different writings for the general public is the beauty of the body, the internal beauty of the body. It just takes my breath away every single day.
现在，我试图在为公众撰写的不同文章中传达的一件事，就是身体的美，身体内部的美。它每天都让我屏住呼吸。
It's funny. I don't think beauty is the first word I would have thought of in this moment.
很有趣。我觉得“美”不是那一刻我首先会想到的词。
Uh-huh. Yeah, this is not the most beautiful heart.
嗯。是的，这不是最美的心脏。
They hooked the patient up to something called the heart-lung machine. A big part of these procedures is outsourcing the work of the heart and the lungs to this big boxy kind of robot with rotating drums in it. This is how they pull off the grand illusion, tricking the body into operating without the heart. They send the patient's blood to the machine. It oxygenates and pressurizes the blood and also cools it and then sends it back to the kidneys and the liver and the lungs, all the organs.
他们把病人连接到一种叫“心肺机”的东西上。这些手术的很大一部分是把心脏和肺的工作外包给这个旋转着转鼓的大盒子一样的机器人。这就是他们完成大错觉的方式，欺骗身体在没有心脏的情况下运作。他们把病人的血液送到机器里。它为血液充氧并增压，也给它降温，然后送回肾脏、肝脏和肺部，所有器官。
And you can see that we meticulously remove all bubbles. Because bubbles could cause a stroke.
你可以看到，我们一丝不苟地移除了所有气泡。因为气泡可能导致中风。
Bubbles from the blood.
血液中的气泡。
Yeah, bubbles from air in the blood. We remove them all very carefully. So you see now, Sean, that the heart has collapsed because we've taken all the blood out.
是的，血液里空气形成的气泡。我们非常小心地移除了它们。所以你看，肖恩，现在心脏已经塌陷了，因为我们把所有血液抽走了。
Dr. E clamps off the aorta right above the aneurysm. That takes the heart out of the circuit. They also send a supercold paralyzing fluid to it called retrograde, or retro for short. So the heart isn't even trying to contract anymore. Now the patient's vital signs have almost totally ceased. No pulse, of course, because his heart isn't beating, very little brain activity.
埃医生在动脉瘤正上方夹住了主动脉。这把心脏从循环系统中移除了。他们还向它输送一种叫“逆行液”的超冷麻痹液体，简称“retro”。所以心脏甚至不再尝试收缩了。现在病人的生命体征几乎完全停止。当然没有脉搏，因为心脏没有跳动，大脑活动也非常少。
But it looks like this particular patient isn't as bad off as others. So they don't end up having to cool him all the way down to 64 degrees. When they do that, it means zero brain activity, no signs of life whatsoever. And when the patient's that cold, they actually turn off the heart-lung machine, which means no blood flow to the brain, so no oxygen. Under those conditions, it's a race against time. They have 45 minutes to an hour to operate before the brain starts to die.
但看起来这个特定的病人情况并不像其他人那么糟糕。所以他们最终不必将他降温到华氏64度。当他们那样做时，意味着大脑活动为零，完全没有生命迹象。当病人那么冷的时候，他们实际上关闭了心肺机，这意味着没有血液流向大脑，所以没有氧气。在这种情况下，这是一场与时间的赛跑。他们有45分钟到一个小时的手术时间，在大脑开始死亡之前。
Meanwhile, this patient's heart has been beating for more than 62 years since before he was born-- is still. Most of us, when our hearts stop, it'll mean they're never going to start again. And that'll happen to this guy eventually, too, of course. But this is just a timeout for the heart, a break. I like to think of it as a mini vacation after a lifetime of constant labor in the pump house.
与此同时，这个病人的心脏已经跳动了超过62年——自他出生前就开始了——现在静止了。大多数人，当我们的心脏停止跳动，意味着它们将永远不会再开始。当然，那最终也会发生在这些人身上。但这只是心脏的暂停，一个休息。我喜欢把它当作泵房里终身恒定劳动后的一个小假期。
Now he's opening the aorta, and you're looking inside, Sean. Now you can see the cavernous dimensions of that aorta.
现在他切开了主动脉，你正在向里面看，肖恩。现在你能看到那个主动脉的深邃维度。
It's huge.
太大了。
Yeah, we could give it a zip code.
是的，我们可以给它编个邮政编码。
Now they set about the actual mechanical work they're in there to do. First, they replace the aortic valve, which is all calcified. And then they swap out the bulgy part of the aorta with a synthetic tube. And after about 2 and 1/2 hours, they're pretty much done. And it's time to bring the patient back to life. Dr. E calls for the official de-airing maneuvers-- that is, evacuating any excess air out of the heart before they let it fill back up again with blood. And suddenly, it's like he's a movie director on set, complete with lots of industry terms I didn't understand.
现在他们开始进行他们在那儿要做的实际机械工作。首先，他们更换了钙化的主动脉瓣。然后他们用一根合成管子换掉了主动脉隆起的部分。在2个半小时后，他们基本完成了。现在是时候让病人活过来了。埃医生要求进行正式的“排气操作”——也就是在让血液重新灌注之前，清除心脏中任何多余的空气。突然间，他就像片场的电影导演，充满了我不懂的各种工业术语。
OK, so let a little blood flow through the heart. Run some retro for de-airing. And we'll take a half dozen nice valsalvas please.
好的，让一点血液流过心脏。运行一些“retro”进行排气。请来半打漂亮的瓦氏操作（valsalvas）。
Valsalvas are deep breaths. The anesthesiologist can actually control the motion of the patient's lungs. Next, Dr. E needs to unclamp the aorta to put the heart back into the circuit.
瓦氏操作是深呼吸。麻醉师实际上可以控制病人肺部的运动。接下来，埃医生需要解开主动脉夹，把心脏放回循环系统中。
Low flow for the clamp. The aorta is unclamped back up slowly. Valsalva down, retro off. All the flow to you. Red on, green on, warm all the way.
夹子低流量。主动脉缓慢解开。瓦氏操作向下，关闭“retro”。所有流量归你。红色开启，绿色开启，全部升温。
Retro, again, is that paralyzing fluid. So they turned that off. Red and green are both drainage tubes. And that's just what color they are. And warm all the way means back to the world of 98.6 degrees. No scrambled albumin.
“Retro”，再说一次，是那种麻痹液体。所以他们关掉了它。红色和绿色都是排水管。这就是它们的颜色。而“全部升温”意味着回到华氏98.6度的世界。没有“炒白蛋白”。
So now the heart is starting to beat again.
所以现在心脏开始再次跳动。
It is. That's a good observation.
是的。那是很好的观察。
At this point, the patient's heart, the violent thing I was so afraid of in the beginning, is much more docile. It looks more like a big chicken breast to me now. Dr. E says that probably means I'm getting hungry, which I was. I'm not someone who tends to seek out intense experiences. I'm not really adventurous. I don't dream about traveling to faraway places.
此时，病人的心脏，那个我最初害怕的暴力东西，温顺多了。我现在觉得它更像一块大鸡胸肉。埃医生说那可能意味着我开始饿了，事实也确实如此。我不是那种倾向于追求强烈体验的人。我不是很爱冒险。我不梦想去遥远的地方旅行。
But looking inside of another human being like that, watching a group of people open him up, fix what's wrong, and close him again, felt as unusual and unlikely as visiting the moon. It's a place I've probably never visit again. And I didn't even know the guy. I didn't even meet him or say hello. I hope he's doing OK.
但像那样观察另一个人，看着一群人切开他，修复错误，再次缝合，感觉就像去月球一样不同寻常且不可能。这是一个我可能再也不会去的地方。我甚至不认识那个家伙。我甚至没见过他或打个招呼。我希望他过得好。
Sean Cole is one of the producers of our show. Dr. John Elefteriades has a memoir about his career as a heart surgeon. It's called Extraordinary Hearts.
肖恩·科尔是我们节目的制片人之一。约翰·埃莱夫特里亚德斯医生有一本关于他作为心脏外科医生职业生涯的回忆录。书名叫《非凡的心脏》（Extraordinary Hearts）。
[MUSIC - "HOW CAN YOU MEND A BROKEN HEART" BY AL GREEN]
[音乐 - 艾尔·格林（Al Green）的《你怎么修补一颗破碎的心》]
Well, our program was produced today by Bim Adewunmi. The people who put our show together today includes Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Chana Jaffe-Walt, Andrea Lopez Cruzado, Tobin Low, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ari Saperstein, Alissa Shipp, Laura Starcheski, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Managing editor, Sarah Abdurrahman. Senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
好吧，我们的节目今天由比姆·阿德温米制作。今天参与制作我们节目的工作人员包括：埃尔娜·贝克、苏珊·伯顿、达娜·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、阿维娃·德科恩费尔德、查娜·杰夫-沃尔特、安德烈亚·洛佩兹·克鲁扎多、托宾·洛、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、阿里·萨珀斯坦、阿丽莎·希普、劳拉·斯塔切斯基、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。总编辑，莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。资深编辑是大卫·克斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。
Special thanks today to Aleks Kalininskiy, Besima Majetic, Sergio Lopez, Leon Gold, Alanna Thiede, Angelina Mosher-Salazar, Josie Rourke, Melanie Belkin, Shelby Howick, and Mark D'Antonio. Mitchell S. Jackson's book where he writes about his mom's blood donations and so much more is called Survival Math.
今天特别感谢：亚历克斯·卡林斯基、贝西玛·马杰蒂奇、塞尔吉奥·洛佩兹、里昂·戈尔德、阿兰娜·泰德、安吉丽娜·莫舍-萨拉查、乔西·罗克、梅拉妮·贝尔金、谢尔比·霍威克和马克·丹东尼奥。米切尔·S·杰克逊撰写关于他母亲献血及更多内容的书叫《生存数学》（Survival Math）。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free. Thanks, as always, to our program's confounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he is counting down the days till Memorial Day.
《美国生活》通过公共广播交流中心（PRX）传送给公共广播电台。我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们超过700集的节目存档。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他正在倒数距离阵亡将士纪念日的日子。
Oh my god. I'm going to wear white pants again.
天哪。我又可以穿白色裤子了。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周我会带着《美国生活》的更多故事回来。
[MUSIC - "HOW CAN YOU MEND A BROKEN HEART" BY AL GREEN]
[音乐 - 艾尔·格林（Al Green）的《你怎么修补一颗破碎的心》]